I computer quantistici affrontano problemi che non possono essere risolti
dai computer classici, problemi come
trovare i materiali giusti per abilitare
la cattura del carbonio per combattere davvero
il cambiamento climatico, per sviluppare
fertilizzanti più efficienti che possano
non danneggiare la terra ma al contempo preservare la
catena di approvvigionamento alimentare di cui abbiamo bisogno per nutrire il mondo.
Ci sono anche domande fondamentali su come il nostro universo
sia strutturato e su come la materia si comporti a livello atomico
e subatomico, cose che dobbiamo capire.
È la prossima frontiera.
Prendiamo un'area in cui la ricerca è già in corso:
la ricerca di nuove batterie.
Le batterie hanno trasformato la nostra vita permettendoci di portare con noi
computer e smartphone,
ma c'è ancora molto da fare: le batterie sono fondamentali
per il nostro futuro energetico pulito,
che si tratti di alimentare auto elettriche o davvero
di spingere le energie rinnovabili.
Abbiamo bisogno di una chimica fondamentalmente diversa
per creare le batterie
del futuro. Il calcolo quantistico
ci permetterebbe di guardare efficacemente all'interno della batteria
durante le sue reazioni molto complesse, per consentirci di
pensare a nuovi materiali
e alla struttura delle batterie che serviranno
per alimentare la prossima generazione di dispositivi.
Come ci arriviamo? Costruendo i dispositivi quantistici più avanzati al mondo
e una piattaforma di sviluppo,
rendendola disponibile al mondo intero.
Solo lavorando insieme adesso
potremo risolvere i problemi che dovremo affrontare
insieme in futuro.